my heart goats out to sir david's wife
to his children his wider family his
staff and all of his friends and
colleagues
today is a dark and a shocking day
the more so because
heartbreakingly we've been here before
informed by his faith sir david had a
profound sense of public duty
and he was highly respected and much
liked across the houses of parliament on
all sides and within the christian
community
we now have to come together in response
to this horrendous act
and show that violence intimidation and
threats
will never prevail over the tireless
work of public servants like david
simply doing his job
thank you and you know you would have
come across him and you know worked
alongside him for many years what was he
like as a person as an mp
he was much respected he had that
profound sense of duty was driven by his
faith
and that's why
across the parties across parliament he
was so respected
and so liked and there's a very profound
sense of loss i think across
politics across
faith and up and down the country
and as you mentioned yourself you know
this comes that feels very close to the
tragic loss of your colleague joe cox
what do you think needs to happen now in
terms of security for mps when they're
having constituency meetings well there
are many questions i think that
are still there but i think today is a
day when all of our thoughts
and all of our focus are with sir
david's family
um and um there are questions for other
days but today our thoughts our prayers
our focus is on them